hold up is that Joe exotics husband
kissing on too hot to handle star Brice
Hirschberg well let's break it down
that's Tiger Kings Dillon passage
partying on a boat with Brice over the
weekend when you grow up in a city
that's just full of amazing gorgeous
people you have to really stand out oh
they did
Dillon flew across the country to
celebrate Bryce's 30th birthday in
Marina del Rey California the Netflix
buds seemed super close dancing
side-by-side and having a good old time
[Music]
the 30 year olds cast mate Matthew
Steven Smith was also on board
this is Bryce's birthday let's show us
out meanwhile Bryce told ET earlier this
year that he and Nicole O'Brien started
dating after filming it's not an
official title Nicole and I have kind of
been kind of been talking and she
visited in LA and a little bit thing and
she's been making visits and whatnot and
Dylan is still married to Joe exotic Joe
is currently serving a 22-year prison
sentence on multiple charges including
murder for hire and animal abuse this is
my way of living
and nobody's gonna tell me any other way
but don't worry Dylan says Joe isn't the
jealous type et spoke to Dylan in April
and he opened up about his marriage to
Joe admitting the former zookeeper would
support him if he were to pursue another
relationship while Joe is behind bars he
doesn't want me to be alone forever you
know if if I do ever meet somebody that
I feel like is gonna be very important
to me then you know Joe would be
perfectly fine and maybe I wouldn't seem
perfectly fine but he would support my
decision to be happy again and it seems
like Dylan celebrated another birthday
that was too hot to handle
the tiger king star hung out with Harry
jiaozi in Los Angeles green idea really
did Dylan posted this photo of the two
posing in front of a car writing my
first trip to LA was epic glados spent
it with you for your 23rd next time
you're coming to Florida
[Music]